mr scott
okay come inside quick
i feared they had to coach you
right about now hanukkah is the most
famous missing person
in the world i am aware
so every arasaka soldier is on our trail
you're right let us not waste any time
i offered her some tea you kidnapped
hanukkah our soccer and offer her a cup
of [ __ ] tea yes she respectfully
declined
tell her the truth about yolinov no
embellishment
and state your terms clearly perhaps to
you
she will listen
to
[Music]
i was there that night at kenpecki plaza
i saw sabiro arasaka die
he wasn't poisoned that's a lie your
brother made up and
spread yorinobu is the murderer
you must be mad to think i will listen
to such nonsense
why my word means [ __ ] to you
i apologize on his behalf oh shut up
garo
we're supposed to be honest well that's
what i'm being
fine maybe i am just a two-bit thief
but i'm the two-bit thief that stole
that [ __ ] relic off you
slotted it in took a bullet to the brain
died
you died oh yeah
and now i got johnny [ __ ] silver hand
in there and i'll do anything to get him
out
so i got exactly nothing to lose but you
got lots
he is living proof of the terrible crime
your brother committed
we can confirm every word he speaks if
only you will help him with the relic
did you hear that go and check
go
i got a bad feeling about this
another extremist
last chance to get the [ __ ] out of here
forget him guys unless you want to wind
up like him
keep it
thank you later need to find a way out
fast
your empty rooms to the right it's our
only chance
open it up
go go
[Music]
he attacked me
uh
my
go go
oh [ __ ] be careful
we must go different ways along we have
a better chance
really think so then go now
i think they make these motels
especially for royal fuck-ups like us
ac's busted dirty needles under the
mattress
[ __ ] clogged
no for real who [ __ ] comes here to
sleep
we're a couple miles outside night city
someone leaving town just keeps driving
somebody going there sleeps in the damn
city what good's a motel in the middle
of nowhere
yet just two [ __ ] losers
and i thought we were screwed when goro
kidnapped hanako
see decide to cross a corp this is what
happens
you think you just stepped in [ __ ]
actually you fell
head first into a cesspit anyone knocked
blast the [ __ ] door no warning
and if it's goro who are you kidding
been 24 hours since we split up complete
radio
silence rest in peace
bastard
saw him yourself even without his
implants he was a good fighter
he'll pull through doesn't matter how
good you are in night city
on your own you're [ __ ]
hear that car
at this hour in this place
[ __ ] just one
finger on the tricky
not a word i have a message for v
don't touch that door i know you're in
there
finally ugh that on the wall
is that blood yeah
knock the last star off this dump
so you were saying got a message
sitting right here
[Music]
it'll start soon what'll start
it's a doll poor proxy
[Music]
i must make one thing clear i still
think you are mad hanako that you
but i can fool myself no longer
i believe you
[Music]
how'd you find me did you really think
it would be enough to leave the city
takamura mentioned he had placed a
tracker on you
yet even had he not when arasaka wishes
to find someone
it finds them porcelain [ __ ]
okay so now that you know and believe
what's next
yarinobu planted a tanto in the
corporation's very heart
i must act while a wound is fresh and
you will help me
you are living proof of his crime and
treason
[Music]
you're gonna help me first perhaps i did
not speak clearly
we must act quickly well i'm pretty
tight on time too
dying in fact my dead body would make
for a pretty lame-ass witness
i understand wanna know everything you
know about mikoshi
mikoshi one of my father's flagship
projects
a data fortress with servers situated on
orbital stations all around earth
think of it as an archive of personality
constructs
digitized psyches try a prison
a matter of perspective in any case that
is not where you will find
salvation not without extensive
knowledge of the relic and the construct
creation procedure
track daniel run away hellman was hiding
under kangtal's wing
we chatted think sooner or later the
engram will completely conceal me
process can't be stopped a surprisingly
deterministic conclusion for a man of
science
at the very least i got my hands on the
relic schematics
got detailed information about its inner
workings project tech documentation
all useful even more so given that
hellman is still alive
i will contact him and explain that one
does not leave arasaka by the back door
man i should make contact with alt
cunningham
the cunningham the very same who
invented soul killer
using her modified version now
that should be more than useful that's
about the extent of what we've got
what now
let us meet in person at embers
in the city center it is discreet
just remember one thing from now on we
both must exercise
extreme caution
well that's my job done
you know what what i think i'd rather
had a wave of suck elites barging here
right because at least we dealt with
soccer henchmen before
but this it's something new
glad to see you get it we've just landed
on very thin ice
crash landed